there was a special show for the 50th
birthday of the Prince of Wales Prince
Charles and and they were on and I was
emptying it or whatever it was hosting
and there was a lineup afterwards and
they were they didn't care that was all
girl power you know as the Prince wasn't
wonderful thank you so much he got to
them and the first thing I'm Emma
bunting basis to him yet she said she
said Oh sir Sir highness sir Sir um do
you have a Prince Albert he said yes I'm
his gregory grandson yes no do you have
one well he was the husband of Queen
Victoria no better and he looked at me
completely baffled that he didn't know
what - Prince Albert was so I had to say
well so it's a it's an item of intimate
jewelry what do you mean I said no
service and he had to have a lie-down
their spunk is equated to you know to
put it you know - it's a nice break yeah
- I think we have a picture of the met
them there he is
yes everyone seems very distracted by
Jerry
mr. I was just pointing at her absent
mindedly you did tell me I think it's
okay to repeat this but the principal's
did tell me once that the best piece of
advice his father had ever given him
said when when you're doing a photograph
and you're doing a line up and there are
women always look only into their eyes
don't for a second that your eyes drop
to their chest because that's when the
photograph goes on look he's not looking
down at all the rest of us even asked
gay boys are looking
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]